AGT was an entertaining hot mess last
night and Taylor Swift has shed her
snakeskin and has emerged edgier than
ever what a night it was at America's
Got Talent
I was there and it is so hard not to be
obsessed with this show I mean there
were stunts and dances plagued with
technical difficulties dogs dressed like
wild animals doing the conga and tears
of course all the tears but the real
waterworks came courtesy of Mel B last
week she served us mystique vibes and
last night she brought the storm
literally and you know who got served
some scary spice Simon Cowell he should
know if you say something inappropriate
it's gonna get like stuff thrown at him
how does this make you feel right now
I'm kind of arriving this would be like
mobis wedding nights a lot of Aunt
dissipation not much promise or delivery
do you think across the line tonight I
just hope I would have had like
cranberry juice in there are some
thirsty and his whole body be really
sticky
Yanis how did that end did you guys have
some words during commercial commercial
break I told you he was not coming back
I was thinking I think she wishes that
there was some coffee in that cup from
the hot hot coffee I was a tense I mean
they do get tense but they love each
other you know and it's all I mean that
you know they having fun at the same
time I mean she loves it he's the boss
pouring water over his head it's pretty
hilarious hilarious for us sure but I'm
not so sure it was for Simon because he
skipped the red carpet entirely after
last night's show
licking up his wounds or drying his
shirt we will never know now for a night
that seemed like everything that could
go wrong did there were still some
standout emotional moments one in
particular that got me was Simon's
golden buzzer Mandy Harvey
Mandy is a deaf singer who won everyone
over last night with this touching
performance and it was an original song
[Music]
I want to know how you're feeling after
laying out all those emotions that's how
I feel like is it's just crazy you know
I I picked a really special song for me
because my cousin is my best friend and
so I got to write that song for her to
walk down the aisle for her wedding so
for me it was already emotional and then
I turned and I saw all these people
giving me deaf applause and then it hit
me even harder and then I turned and I
saw my parents and my husband and my
friends and my band and I was just I
lost it for Simon I just really want to
make him proud because he used his one
buzzer on on me and I I just hope I hope
that it touched people and I hope that
it was enough you definitely touch
people I want to ask you what do you
hope people take away from your story
I've gotten a lot of emails and a lot of
messages thousands of thousands of
people who are hurting or they're
dealing with loss and it just has become
so obvious that no matter who you are
you will deal with something and it's so
much of a hope to know that we're all in
this together and I think that we all
have a responsibility to encourage other
people and we'll lift them up there's
such darkness in the world why not shine
some light through anything that we can
do whether that's saying hi to a
stranger or holding the door for someone
it doesn't have to be huge but we can
change the world in small steps
well said Mandy you know talking to her
last night I witnessed firsthand just
how inspiring she is but you know what
else gave me chills last night ariana
grande on carpool karaoke the series at
this point we know the little pop-tart
has the voice of a diva but she's also a
theater kid and she proved this during
her duet of suddenly Seymour from The
Musical Little Shop of Horrors with a
little assist from Seth MacFarlane now
if you missed it you gotta check it out
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
like what come on now they almost
crashed but they did not miss a beat
because as already said when you are a
theater person you stay in it
alright now time to slither our way to
Taylor Swift
she's been teasing new music since April
and now her long-awaited album has been
revealed to be called reputation now
listen to this the first single will
come out tomorrow the same day as Katy
Perry's music video for swish-swish
coincidence I think not
okay so what does the deal with the
snake though let me remind you that it's
something Taylor's been called a lot in
the past after Kanye called Taylor a bee
and his song famous allegedly without
permission
Kim snapchatted and Taylor fired back I
want to be excluded from this narrative
and then Kim sent this thinly veiled
tweet aimed at Taylor on wait for it
national snake day so I don't think it's
just Katy she was going after she's done
with boyfriends and breakups and it's
looking like her feuds will be the
inspiration for these new songs and I
gotta tell you I am here for this rough
around the edges Taylor Swift and look
what a difference ten years makes from
her debut album she is mad and I'm here
for it all so can we talk about how the
font of reputation is giving me some
poplar vibes as in Kanye's pablo
coincidence I think not
now speaking of Kanye his ex Amber Rose
has apparently achieved the ultimate
form of closure but not with easy but
with her ex-boyfriend Wiz Khalifa amber
has officially covered her tattoo of
Wiz's face on her arm with what appears
to be slash from Guns and Roses I don't
even think she and slash are dating I
just think she wanted to show Wiz that
there are musicians she likes more than
him and that my friends is as cold as a
snake and we have a fish leak Oh full
circle and today daily Dedinje now I
show up with the tattoo of Beyonce on my
arm tomorrow you know my relationships
are going badly okay you guys know the
deal like comment share I love you
thanks for watching and good bye she's a
cold-hearted snake oh yeah